[Music]
okay guys i have a story here
of this hair salon that was
that was so oh yeah right we were
talking about hair off camera
so this hair salon they they were
running
a job advertisement
job posting yeah yeah okay listing
that's listing that's what we call it
it's because this is a british article
and they call it a
job nazi nazi page and a job advert
like in advertising yes that's why i
said
anyway so they were they did a job
listing and under it they were looking
for a
happy stylist and then so they submitted
it
to the place that we're going to print
this this out this listing style is
like a monster.com or a linkedin type of
thing um
yeah something like that what's a happy
style i'm thinking happy endings
i was thinking someone with like
positive energy optimistic yeah
yeah so you're like a hair stylist but
they're looking for someone happy
requirement okay so this is the entire
thing it must be happy it says part-time
fully qualified hairdresser must be
confident and barbering as well as all
aspects of hairdressing must have at
least
five years experience working in a salon
after being fully qualified
this is a busy friendly small salon so
only happy friendly stylists need apply
no okay that makes i mean that makes
sense it's like one of those like
we just want we want positive energy
don't come in here with your diva stuff
i love the whole must be confident
because do they have hair stylists that
aren't they're like
oh i'm not sure i'm sorry
i don't know for them but i have one of
my friends tattoo artists where he's
dope
but then he'll post on his clothes
around he's like i don't know about this
one i'm like dude like you can't be
you can't be doing that because that's
like it's perfect after he's done he's
like yeah
i don't know keep those thoughts
yourself holy [ __ ] wait he does it
in front of his clients now be hilarious
[Laughter]
no but he he can't hide his emotions so
he's not happy
he's good though but he's good they're
loving it but he's just like
in front of the music oh my dude this is
permanent you can't be doing that you
have to fake it
i would i i'd freak out [ __ ] yeah i have
no tattoos so of course i'd freak out in
that day oh no that takes a lot because
i've been trying to get him by him but
he's like
he's like let me get better i'm like
it's dope i love your [ __ ] already uh if
somebody tells me let me get better um
take your time let's get get better that
would probably traumatize me to never
get a tattoo
ever i don't have one i'm just like
[ __ ] i'm getting one in a week
yeah your first one what are you getting
uh well i'm getting
two done so i'm getting a knife and then
it's like an afghan knife and then the
afghan
is it a curly sword knife no not that
one i'm getting that on the back
of my neck like right below the trap
like a scissors when it's two knives
together
grandma's name oh and then my mom's name
yes yeah
for really two tattoos that's like two
touches in a week
and then the rest of this in the next
two months all by the same artist
by the guy that was hesitant well
there's a bug that was crawling on your
shoulder
i have one trapped right here on a
battery so i wanted to study it oh my
god what the hell is this
look people where's the [ __ ] off she
picked it up
what is that i thought you were a bra
girl what is this
she's a hybrid she's a hybrid high
friend yeah
let's study some bugs usually i probably
would not be doing this but this is
pretty interesting oh [ __ ] i like go by
accident
is it gonna fly away oh i got it again
let me just take it outside
no it's just hello there's a hell of a
man just let it go
tiff they're gonna die in any way a
thousand in here you don't have to worry
about sometimes
i'm not really afraid of a lot of bugs
but i don't pick them up i think we need
to set up that you know what i'm saying
i don't ex i don't
we not doing this to the bugs normally i
would have never done that
i don't know what camera your confidence
was crazy
you had no fear you said what is this
look at this look at this right here
yeah how come you didn't get freaked out
this one time i don't know why
what you usually do did i give you oh
i'm in a dress today you get prissy
nikki knock it off
it depends on how the bug looks to me if
it looks okay
that looks like it looked like a pincher
bug but i was flying that was flying
like a big ant i don't [ __ ] with pincher
no you look like a big ad
it didn't have a pincher though so
that's why when i saw it on him
what i saw on him looked like a pincher
bug and then it flew
and those things freaked me out because
i pictured bugs pincher bugs they look
pretty nasty they're
they're scary looking so in my mind you
had to pinch your butt and i'm like oh i
don't [ __ ] with that this
house had a big dick did you see it i
did not i didn't i tried to like peep
over because i was like okay am i really
that scared but it's cause it's flying
and i don't know if you're the type of
person to throw it at me oh no
i didn't know if you were the type i've
been traumatized like look at the book
oh no so messed up me too that's why i
would never do that right but then when
he said oh she wants to see that i was
like oh you do but then they saw you
freaking out so i'm like no
well first things first she was like
that's so cute that you wanted to show
me the book i was like get the [ __ ] off
of him it was like a bug's life
like the ant yeah it was weird it was
weird it looked
strange i saw one on the bounce board
too just crawling
where are they coming from i'm thinking
up there
they're coming in from somewhere maybe
it's too hot outside
it's hot right now they're starting to
come oh it's intense
[ __ ] they don't pay for the ac maybe
it's the end of the world maybe
i don't well if it is it's cool i'm
having fun i've seen bugs before this
okay anyway okay i would run a ribeye
steak though right before i die oh
that'd be good that would be your last
meal i like rib eye sticks no
wagyu
i know i like this i like the taste of
skirt but i think ribeye is my hands
down favorite steak in the whole entire
world look i'm really hungry
i know that's quick i know lunch is late
okay new york's these days
so we were talking about hair salon okay
being happy
happy happy hair confident and happy all
right so it turns out
that for this ad she this salon
ended up getting um this notification
that said that
they will not be running this ad because
it discriminates against
unhappy people is that true
yeah there's a bunch of unhappy people
that need jobs and uh
you know you can't be like you can't
come here because you're unhappy but
can't you
but it's your job that you're posting
for don't you get to discriminate
somebody's not qualified for the job
then
isn't that a part of the hiring party i
feel like that's not part of
discrimination in terms of like race and
gender
right that's why i'm confused because
overall work environment
if that person isn't conducive to the
overall
uh i think if they were saying we're
looking specifically
for a person of this color or height
this is a requirement
but whatever those things you can't
change like happiness you can
choose to be happy or unhappy but a lot
of people don't believe that
they'll be like i got depression give it
or [ __ ] take it or leave it
and leave it but if me as an employer
for for my
especially because this is a service
industry this isn't like in the tech
where you don't have to interact with
other people your attitude can
really affect the business yeah help
reviews
that's true someone should have a hair
salon that's like i want some
sad [ __ ] to work for me oh
that's
good you look so much better than i do
and you kind of get them
no no no no no no no but then they could
be sad and be like she looks so much oh
i didn't mean to do that
and all your hair is gone yeah so i'm
like how is that a good thing
what about just sad and down so then
like when you feel down too you both
can talk about some down [ __ ] together
but can't you lose your job for having a
terrible attitude and you're no longer
and you're scaring away clients
exactly not at my hair salon i mean
again this is in california because we
know california rules are very different
we're like yeah
you can yeah yeah yeah this isn't
in the uk in the uk well at least it's
discriminatory
i mean i guess if you want to be sad
hairstylists go to the uk
you can get a job out there they won't
discriminate bad ass hair cutter
hey where you going i'm getting a sad
ass haircut
some sad people i'm looking forward to
that [ __ ]
like man i got some [ __ ] to talk about
like i don't want to go to this happy
salon because they're always trying to
bring my spirits up
[ __ ] dude i want to vent right now
therapy cuts
and you're like you do it no you know oh
[ __ ] no you know they actually do that
they're training there's some like
hairstylists or like barber shop people
that they're
they train in counseling really yeah
well i mean we do talk a lot yeah this
is a straight up thing i usually feel
like i'm
helping the barber out because
huh do you feel better after no i feel
worse because i'm like your life sucks
bro
like you're going through an affair and
all this [ __ ] i'm like how are you 15
years older and your life is in shambles
wait he's going through it so he's like
i can't stop cheating on myself yeah
what what's the situation no we need to
know
hold on does this guy watch these videos
oh yeah you know what
you have shouted out your barber shop uh
people put together
i went to another barber shop in san
francisco
yeah it was a sad ass barber academy off
of hate street
so yeah damn i love my hairstyle so
she's
she's dope have you ever listened to her
hair hair places where they do uh
the quiet ones the but they don't talk
to you yeah the silent ones
i like those i would want to go to one i
feel like once you find your hair like
you go through a bunch of different
hairstylists and barbers until you find
your person and then once you find your
person that's it
you're in a relationship we're together
yeah exactly i'm just putting up with
mine
how did i know for guys i live in
another city now and then so it's a pain
in the ass to have to drive like 30 40
minutes and i found another guy and it's
been going to him
and he's pretty cool and we told him
we'd pay him more if he comes here
but do you feel like you're cheating on
like your barber if you
i told him i'm up front like that yeah
yeah i feel weird too because my my
original hair
hair girl or like the the one before
this one
she was the one that i was going to all
the time but she gets booked up for like
months in advance and i'm like i don't
plan like that i can't plan my life like
months in advance like that so how often
do you have to get your hair done
not even that crazy honestly i mean we
see how we make it work
well when my hair is dark it's a
different story but i my
my natural hair is your color my natural
hair is like black
thank you yeah it's dope it's amazing
but since i went like this you it's like
more high maintenance but my hair
stylist like she has to go away from
time to time and i'm like
i like this one she she shows up to the
house when i need her
oh she's she's loyal i mean she's loyal
she's down she's dope shout out andrea i
love you
she's like i love her kids i'm like her
all of it
i found my person so i will thug it out
with the roots and all of it so that she
can do my hair and i don't want nobody
else
is she here or in the bay she's out my
way
yeah so she's not in l.a remember i
don't live here where do you live i
don't live in illinois in the bay
in the family oh so you just fly out
here yeah we got it
yeah he's gonna be gone tomorrow i will
be home yeah you better write your love
letters now i know
just train him for what we need
yeah so he's so so when he can't get his
hair done
don't look like a watermelon he has to
learn how to do it himself but you're a
yo but your hairstylist for ladies when
you get your hair
dyed they hate when you go to other
people because they don't know
because they don't know what you put in
your hair so that's why like when you
dye your hair you go to one person and
one person only over and over again
because they know what's in they know
what's going on because your hair can
come out
yes they know the car it's familiar but
barbers
i don't know y'all got yeah they know
your head shape they just remember it
just go balls
yeah they do because like usually like
if you go to my every time i go to a
barber
the first cut is never that good so i
always have to give them like a second
chance because they know where like the
little parts that go in and go out
yeah and then if after the second cut
isn't good then the other guys just
noise
how many barbers do you think you've had
i've had three hair stylists the whole
life
pretty much like three hairs [ __ ] then
like
a lot i can't because how many barber
bodies do you have
barber boxes you just go to a place that
would be like i'll give you i do a five
dollar haircut right now man i'm like
five dollars all right [ __ ] it hook it
up
orange and garvey yup that's the spot
all right well back to this story here
so
it turns out that that was a mistake
when
like the so it was the department for
work and pensions
um that they were the ones who contacted
this hair salon to say that they had a
discriminatory word
in their ad and so they ended up
apologizing and saying and then
they they they went through with the
original ad and they said that that was
a mistake
um but yeah it was just a
misunderstanding but it was kind of
which misunderstanding like
the the fact that the word happy was
discriminatory
okay so it's not discriminatory it's not
so whoever whoever
filed it as a discriminatory thing
hairstylist but because i'm sad
i can't work [ __ ] you don't want to
work there they don't want you here why
do you want to work where they don't
want you
yeah exactly exactly stay in your sad
ass hair salon that's fine go be sad boo
you